the search for survivors after a
powerful series
of earthquakes if of uh explosions
rather in equatorial guinea is underway
at least
20 people were killed hundreds more have
been injured
the blasts tore apart a military base in
the country's most populous city bata
residential areas near the base were
also
obliterated trapping people under rubble
the country's foreign minister has
called for international assistance in
dealing with the disaster
panic confusion and flight
in the city of bata the largest in
equatorial guinea
residents are in shock over the disaster
that struck in their midst
according to the government dynamite
exploded in the city's military barracks
setting off a series of blasts that left
few buildings in bata undamaged the
situation in the city of bata
is that there were a couple of blasts
during this afternoon
and they have caused the loss of several
human lives
as well as substantial material damage
in flattened neighborhoods survivors are
pulled from the rubble
they're brought to hospitals suddenly
overwhelmed with people
injured by the multiple explosions
[Music]
over half of equatorial guinea's 1.4
million inhabitants live in bata
the powerful blasts have shaken not just
the city but the entire
country
our correspondent blaise young is
covering the story for us from boer
in neighboring cameroon blaze what do we
know about the cause of these explosions
thank you uh what we know so far about
the cost of this explosion is basically
from
uh what information we're getting from
the president of the country uh
judo objengema he mentioned in the
televised
message yesterday that this blast was
caused by a mishandling of dynamites
at the at the military base there in
bata
also he also speculated and mentioned
that
there are people who are farming lands
across
the fields farmers who are farming their
fields across
or nearby the military base that they
may have set
fire in their field and this may have uh
caused the blast but that is just what
we know the literal information is
coming from
from the country so far now several
people were killed
many were injured how are hospitals
there coping
hospitals are overwhelmed especially
three main hospitals where the injured
and the victims of these
blasts have been taken to yesterday the
ministry of
health posted several tweets on twitter
asking for equatorial guineans and other
people
who have experience and health and even
volunteers
to go to the hospitals across the city
to make sure that they can volunteer and
help i mean thousands of victims that
are
suffering from this explosion block
donation blocks
is running out so they've asked for
people to donate
blood in hospitals most of these
hospitals are
totally overwhelmed blaze thank you very
much for that
update that was correspondent blaze
aeyong in
buea cameroon
you